son five minutes slow welcome to the
meeting of the standards committees I'm
just going to read out first view the
emergency evacuations and ask you
firstly please note that this meeting
will be audio recorded sure will you be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave them owned by the torch
the fire escape staircase please help
both handrails in case the stairs are
wet or slippery if anyone is unable to
use the stairs when they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape for or where they can
be given assistance our assembly
employment will be the public car park
at the side of the surface please do not
delay or evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to
building until given permission to do so
by council staff we have two apologies
for absence council mrs. Mason and count
releases bingo and I sell there are any
other over 500k and non-members at nu
zijn een minutes of the meeting held on
line 2 3 4 2015 is it your wish that I
sign the steadily d minutes as a true
copy very thin cube and father any
declarations of interest
with regards to me or so because the
parish arming rabanne Pascal's thank you
some names chairman item 6a by virtue of
being a member of ready town council non
peculiar interest thank you say open
yeah ladytown condition yes yes
membership thank you ruptured hundred
thank you and also watch realtor thank
you I determined that that that is it I
your noggin yeah they're non-pecuniary
interests hello no sticky tongue tied
inside mr. Sherman also the district
council a representative for the Roger
hundred so I declare the interest as
well okay thank you very much chairman
I'm also trustee the COV that's right
thanks for that film right now move the
record units dis the standards committee
meeting is that legally of correctly
down along this is the first time in 54
you know we are the council polit we are
allowed to record public this is a
public meeting i have yoga every hands
of every way to their happy but feeling
for you as a committee know me committee
meetings have been recorded just like
you're planning meetings are recorded
okay I'm just going to let a PhD that's
all really should there's no change
okay i think if a spirit resiliency then
we would even you dr. that ties it as
indeed in other similar meetings between
record exactly item file the agenda is
the ledge investigations and
determinations Joe now you're going to
go for these line by line languages
current job to certain it is my it's
about the recommendation is to need to
feed the annual summary of local
investigations etc so I don't think it's
necessary they're like fell apart should
give me a question in more depth or
night need 11 yes I will be going
through page by page night night night
I do the questions on page 52 53 in this
matter I knew 11 about recording God the
myth of the meeting lady where does that
stand I'm not saying he played by the
question well it doesn't quite made that
somebody was not allowed to record them
an heir apparent council meeting and I
wonder what leg was status anybody who's
got in regarding an amazing each other
is not that's not a question I can
answer because this is to do a parish
council meeting I wasn't the launch an
office at the time dealing with that I
could not I mean I do not know the
details and facts of that case to that
could form a complaint was lodged and it
was dealt by that mansion officer I
can't divulge the actual details of that
case I'd like to know me lady Kenna
Kenna parish councils cited am engine
business apothic you're not allowed to
record is mating sorry chairman I'm not
here to give legal advice on separate
issues on it if you'd like so you're
sorry search em and I'm still not
familiar with okay so let me count to
the back is on vice chairman Roger
hundred association of parish councils
counterfeit often a question let's go
and if you want to email me separately I
can deal with that and I'm going to vote
yeah yeah alright so if you want to put
your queries to me separate I can't
actually discuss this cases I don't know
the details of this case
what it appears to me is a situation
since we recalled out our and quite
right people and purposes that you can
listen to me whatever but I think this
particular situation was members of the
public recording again handsome s which
I couldn't a different situation
completely as if if somebody else
outside is recording I don't I would
think that would be in general any
different situation to recording
meat-eaters where you do yeah sure that
comes back to fact that I didn't deal
with a case I would know the details
I'll think you need to find those isn't
that sorry just so I've I'm sorry I'm no
hair done and my sent a first line
saying this chair of barn Parish Council
my understanding is that if the Parish
Council wished to record the meeting
they could do so as we do here we'd have
to make their what he know that we do so
if a member of the public wish to record
or film the parish council meeting my
understanding is that they came but Dad
of courtesy they're required to just let
us know that's my understanding why will
stand corrected if I'm wrong then but
but that's my understanding that's from
May our particular car okay have some
fun yeah go to some kind of looking at
Robyn as well there are take matters
pretty much awesome seven
you have to be notified prior to me to
remember the public be interested in
that particular case I notice that the
complaint it is actually a parish
councillor not never the public the
public may not eventually have an issue
with them thank you can see on it as
chairman stammers Parish Council Audrey
with the counselor steps it up but it is
in the Standing Orders of these Parish
Council rastogi that you're allowed to
record the meetings so is the counselor
in question he asked the representative
look at the Standing Orders yes I say my
understanding was that to record
anything in that situation you will
don't have to notify everybody in the
meeting and get permission for that okay
well I think you're going to do or
you've been invited to email and the
original officer so exists that John
cysts version yeah mr. Chung given
appeared to me that we've got three or
four different councillors compounded or
different versions of it some seem to be
privy to what went on it may be a bit of
idea if we come up with a formula the
hall of the palace
that made aware of the rules by
attempting is for this committee to just
suggesting address standard for the
actual council because if we're not
careful we will recall this you told us
no one is really queried it and luckily
there are no public people here but if
there was it would then set a precedent
that all of the sudden it's a public
meeting rather than if you want enclosed
at the moment and you can see parish
councils out in the field done and why
was that Scott why didn't that happen so
just to be on the safe side it might
kind that we look at it and thank you a
guideline to everybody so you don't have
four councillors coming up excuse me
with different versions just a
suggestion the young district council
did adopt a code of conduct for this
matter which I believe a number of the
parish councils have also adopted as
part of their standard orders so it's I
think that's the way that the parishes
are actually going is to looking at that
we do it and we'll do the same but my
understanding is no the members of
public don't even have to ask their
permission you're not allowed to film
the the members of public so if you've
got chemical swing around on to the
public benches if you like but all you
have to do is to notify that you will be
recording that is my understanding
yeah okay and 5.65 boys age
members the recommended daily chat I'm
sorry just a quickie I'm is it the first
time series it's just for the last year
we seem to have a lot of complaints
count they have counselors I know you
just say the better except I've got a
code of conduct market Mighty Mite being
is going through his I don't have ever
seen so many complaints in a whole year
district council district councillor and
just wondering if there's any nothing we
can do about it but maybe I don't know
is training or counter steps i said in
the code of conduct norms I'm just
concerned that's all I know there's lots
of things that it hasn't gone through
etcetera etcetera and it's been sorted
it just seems we've had a lot of
complaints of that each anything not
each and every counselor I don't know
who they are but about houses again
started I don't know obviously leads for
one or two and aa me on this district
anymore it just it just fine as you
appreciate so we can't discuss details
you know I kinda heard your complaints
and it is not for us to
festa Gate where the complaints be
justified I think these natural the
mighty like to deal with metroid
appropriate within the procedure laid
down in the code condo yeah thank you
very much yes indeed the code of conduct
training is coming up very shortly kind
of like that if anybody has forgotten
what the rules are and there will be the
opportunity to be reminded that don't
worry maybe better scientist I don't
ever seen as me I'm not so damn i wanna
know who's who i'll just say it's just
to me i'm just thinking that's you got
new council on the air and it's just
that's almost 5i can i tell i think it's
useful to have three years that should
the train ages I everything for long
established to members to do be reminded
about what the Lord oh that's not from
and she doesn't refer to yes I'd he
following on from accounts to Western I
hadn't sat on stands before so I've got
nothing to it to go by in previous years
but we've got 22 flames one of them is
against all councillors so that makes 25
how does that compare 11 years I mean
wonder they don't need to know details I
don't think we've had this to say to you
chairman and from my understanding
taking over from the previous one the
number of complaints you're right has
gone on but a complaints of complaints
nothing I can do about that once you
receive this yeah it's a no rhyme or
reason so in my show it's actually one
more than this because I dealt with one
but then the vultures need dependable
person without that and that's not on
here at least it fits the one the final
ones that the AC is on that so that
article on page well there you go I'm
thinking if it isn't is enough and
I believe it's number 19 so I believe it
may be number 19 it's just the one
person being so which only with those
new to me as a step to you think it I
just wondered whether if there is a
particular trained with the type of
complaints not necessarily to be brought
to our attention but when Lee comes up
to the tribune you mentioned about
that's very training course if there's a
particular trained then perhaps that
training should take that particular
trend into account and emphasize the
issue or do particular training around
that particular a shin chan I didn't
happen don't think there is a particular
trend however as I suggest you jam that
members we are going we're proposing to
email members prior to the training and
for you to ask any questions burning
questions that keep coming up again and
again so that could be your opportunity
to put forward to the trainer so he's
prepared to answer your questions I
couldn't really say that there's a
particular trend in any particular
complaint really couple that judges this
probably stupid question but I'm gonna
ask a way I mean the district
councillors Elena yo no you can't answer
the question you might be to answer
question the district council is it just
in any of these district councillors one
of the same person so if you've got as
you say 18 complaint is that one
cancer doing 18 complaint can we
understand whether are we allowed to
know it could be one counselor is doing
all the complaint don't drop when I who
is or are always complained by every
single different counselor vo chairman
you come it's not one particular
complainant it's not one particularly
those array of this array of different
something that it's maybe a member I
can't tell you whether they which ones
exactly our members poker but some of
them are maybe casiano yet go hand up
now thank you ever coming back to Castle
westerns like I take the point there are
another fair number of complaints on
there but it seems to be that most of
them were close with no further action
or the complaint not being up air and
after investigation
that in itself indicates the training
page because the unclaimed was not a
proper complaining first place it's a
sound a number 19 no bridge of code and
the code of rules can be addressed
through training further than you need
to emphasize I know it's being said but
just don't sighs it because it believes
are saying here and so it just weekly
once i receive a formal complaint
regardless whether there's any teeth in
that complaint i still need to look at
it and then where's yeah so yeah it is
and i think it's fair to say that some
some complaints and i have met some more
knowledge of the manure but i think is
probably reading from this there is a
mix-up between a formal complaint under
the Code of Conduct and the rough and
tumble of politics you know it's yeah
that's the way it is it doesn't
necessarily represent a breach of the
code and therefore could be dealt with
informally in
but saving the only listing here is whom
different plenty zag honest not who's
making complainers says confirm the
game's physically stable first council
see if you don t the members of pie so
chairman and just to be clear on the run
on number 22 days actually a member of
the public that was over something like
behalf that you had to put the complaint
atlantis so that's a reasonable
retaining that is actually a member of
public yeah yeah so did you live on here
average I to 20 soon that sure that was
a complaint by a member of the public
now still all going yes right
disabilities so sort of one very small
it does appear to be one that's been
outstanding for quite a while back in
February and then still these children
especially that just though or has it
did you been gone since Jim that has
been gone since wary because it's moved
on in stages is actually under formal
investigation so the investigation isn't
completed you
so there was the recommendation is that
we commit ourselves as an angle summary
of alleged investigations and
determinations 2050 2014-2015 news of a
year be received as a brain and I 2-6 of
your junior has spread town council
training your some members will see this
they're going immediately to a bar for
stopped on the recommendation cpt with
all the notice for composes or any
questions observations or matters any
member of wishes to raise cash instead
yes died except the report but my
biggest single concern is how do we
encourage the parishes to take up more
training particularly around playing
matches which are very important I think
we need to find a way of encouraging
to do some more so somehow yes chairman
we've all SAT last time you mean our
last meeting we talked about the parity
counselors coming to we may lead to do
with training we thought we were going
to bring something forward to this
Standards Committee well if I gotta come
I interrupt you there I think the
position we reached at the last meeting
was that we couldn't actually received
any sort of recommendation or proposal
until we had this further information we
now have it so having considered is
further information does any member wish
to put forward a proposal for for
example a recommendation to full council
we could obviously can only recommend
will be a matter for full council to
make any design sorry chairman coming
back to that I thought type of being
meeting we had last time we were going
to get some figures or information
together to see what how much training
was done by the parish councillors
especially on it on the plain sight to
fill it we could make a judiciary move
even if it's a charge it counts as
planning and training rather than me is
that enough now
oh just curious today I'm wondering what
was the thinking behind offering health
and well-being and economic development
of free to parish councils when you
don't offer on a district doesn't offer
training on client Prairie the child of
thought has more importance to the work
of the district councils and offering
health and well-being I can't understand
the district's logic been offering
health and well-being on the nights of
July an economic development on the
sixteenth of july it's an offer to the
parishes at no cost and yet there's a
charge for forming its planning not
deemed to be as important then as part
of well being an economic development
now you make recommendations or check
your comments that make sure that but
what they give what they get the
district is local knowledge and they can
give informed local knowledge I'd still
like to know the reasoning behind why
health and well-being and economic
development and see there's no cost
training I'm playing in this a cost
driving
this either the officers are able to
suggest a substantive answer to that I
was like my only view i believe i
express is 15 that was considered to be
appropriate it's strange because it's
the district always favored would offer
yeah that offer training 2013 to be
appropriate so presumably the district
doesn't see planning as appropriate to
parish to parish councils not free see
appropriate but not free i think that
was just-- capacity on the health and
well-being and you cannot develop cause
what else society coming in and they
wanted to be able to cut in it a little
bit quieter they were happy for the
parishes to coming and with the economic
development that certainly something
that involves the parishes as well as a
district so those officers thought it
would be useful to have the parishes
involved I'll take it back to Ashley
because they require venues that loves
to burglary I hope they're healthier
anyway countess nature thank you and I
would like to propose that offer the
planning training and I mean the plan
training to parish councils not
necessary to all that to say one
representative from each council at each
training episode we're not even dating
people because they can then go back and
actually and breathe their own pitiful
also in subjects so I'd like to propose
as easily as a suggestion please enjoy
to enunciate that yeah okay but I like
the clothes that we offer planning
training free of charge the parishes for
one for one member from each parish
council so may I say sir it does yellow
movement is what we discussed last
meeting we were concerned that we won't
get the family involved in training
especially plenty she's going to each
parish and they said Lee there bit about
what with a happy with the item of the
painting because they look coming on
with a plan in training it was a really
discussion I think that's the point we
reach but then we came to the conclusion
that we couldn't actually reach
conclusion now until we had this in
England now the obvious information I
think Carlos teto saying that now in the
light of that information that's if
that's what he wants to propose so i was
thinking like if
that the planning training that the free
of charge for one member from each
parish council poker session planning
train possession yeah and then that way
different members of patient hasn't got
a different plan training not only gets
their down and did y'all have a our
second you can take him that I commanded
yes among that so yeah we know so we're
now speaking to that proposal about this
proposed I have got a concern that
proposal because in the past are one
individual sent on a training course but
the information which was delivered was
diluted somewhat and i would like to
counter proposal that depending on the
numbers of attendees that we charge hose
a reducing scale but i think it was
taken to our pal sorry if you want to
invite council step totally it's not
make items okay usually I say yes or no
go about you come back on that I think
the planning training you're talking
about was the planning training
specifically for parish councils the
planning training are talking about is
the same training as we get as district
and science okay so yes it's not the
dialectic version as you mention yes
about over the next the same as what we
get and be the same thing friday okay
could I just chip in it yes boy oh man I
please do um the mandatory planning
training that we
our counselors is mandatory for all of
our counselors and there's a maximum of
20 spaces on each course that's 20 at
lunchtime 20 in evening so it's a
capacity being really I mean ideally
everyone should attend all of our
counselors should attend each of the
planning courses that is run so it is
just the capacity as soon as we can mix
them train them in because Sean trust
shoulder scotland's actually offering
the training now that me says there's
only one space in because we have 39
counselors that have to be at that
training potentially I mean there is the
option they can they can effectively go
to every other one but they can
potentially come to everyone else was
deadly can I ask what actually sets the
limit of the number it's obviously not
the size of again because it shorten
prefers the way he runs his training is
he prefers it to golf and little break
up groups and so then the Chamber's not
really suitable for that no but I may be
going to get so number people in here if
we had a meeting here we walk around the
table plus members of public that's what
I wore it could happen to exchange it is
just a question of the layout of the
road rather than yeah chemistry and
don't forget some of our counselors our
parish campus anyway yes so again in a
sense hopefully you've got two councils
and two so they they are mandatory to
come on the training you wouldn't
necessarily need one of the others if
you liked over norm counters to come on
on that trailer there's a bit sweeter
bad about so are we saying then good
it was the suggestion relates to the
trainer being free of charge for one
member of a parish council excluding
those who are also District Council's
yet cancel our divisions except with
regardless of venues I couldn't afford
the establishment Warren of all if
opposite which caters up to 200 people
we've got those very facility said to
welcome the new journey not sure that
will go down terribly well with our we
haven't hear them yeah who was having
here the whole geez somebody help the
end up yes thank you Papa's yah i'll
vote all these but looking at it tell me
better at it I'm although I'm very
sympathetic to the fact that the parent
parish council should have planning
treat dragging because although they
don't have a step you know their views
have them statutory value their input is
very important but it needs to be wrong
exalted in portable and looking at the
at the attendance at some courses that
are free and that are now pay for it is
obvious that the cost is an issue and
there is planning training four parishes
but a special training for parachute on
Patty and I would call the battles of my
valuable what route to a goal down I do
wonder whether there is merit in having
a free place for each parish council on
a planning training specifically for
parishes with additional representatives
being painful because if you look at the
planning training parishes of 2014 it's
only for councils it's only for parish
Foxley rainy town council although there
were ten attendees and I'm just
wondering
that would be merited having a free
place up on these specific training four
parishes for one person from each parish
council with additional representatives
paying the phones ground well because he
gave essentially a matter for council
steptoe whether he wants to host our
celebrity I've original proposal okay by
the if the parish council won't send
extra people then because that would be
a childhood dish in their life except
there but I'd still stand by my original
proposal but one member from each pass
council okay no comment Kim then love I
mentioned the Roger district council
representative on the budget hundred and
Inter meeting the cost of the parishes
of training for Rochester Gaza comes up
and obviously the parishes feel very
strongly regards to the cost of the
trailer but varied in mind that most of
the parishes have got budgets for
training which is included in the
preceptor you could argue that is paid
for by Roger District Council anyway
bearing in mind also that the actual
total payment to Russia district council
by the parishes is relatively small I
would like to see of the charge four
parishes for all camper for all training
to simply be abolished well I think
you'll move on to an author they assess
a different proposal indeed we are I'd
like to deal with characters proposal
first okay
if you want clothes on and then have a
second day we can come on to that okay
wish okay so are we all clear as to the
home get away with since I on laxatives
okay with your eyes reason just you
saying what exactly this is this one
that one that planned that one space one
space on each planning training course
is offered free of charge to each of the
parish councils just plan yeah gently
was just planning on strength then I
just horrified that is each training
session we have here as district
councillors it perished and offer come
can send one parish councillor not just
one parish councillor at all
professional skier nothing oh yeah
pinion which is like okay I can't
specifically I saw her typically yes I'm
just concerned that same we say with it
it is limited to 20 here I think we've
got to go back and and simply Glee the
numbers that can come on to these
courses because we've got to keep 3939
spaces for the district councillors
because that is compulsory that they
have to do that train so that
realistically will only give one space
I'm available so are we in a position
right now to say that we could do this
and if we're saying that is easy 20 each
tile excellent well but maybe it could
be
and is subject to available space I
think not for the planning nothing blow
oh right I'm there for this stench
priority has got to be given to district
councillors because it is compulsory
training children well we won why don't
they were saying they weren't we
witnessed necessarily accommodate them
merely that he bought one place will be
free of charge should they should all
parastatals take the Opera should should
all parish councils take that off for
our I'm sending well quite is a
counselor
but that would apply whether they're
paying for it or not council said red I
think he's too perhaps legal counsel as
butchers concerns I think it says down
to the layout of this room because you
could have 20 councillors around the
table here for a meeting Plus members of
public in this room so unless somebody
to tell me there's a limit to the amount
of people were allowed in this room I
enter the fire regulations then I just
think it's down to the layout of the
room rather than the physical number
that's pretty sure I thought it had
already been suggested that if a parish
council had a district councillor on it
it was that district councillors
responsibility to report back to the
parish on the planning meeting the
training that had taken place in which
case you're probably only looking at a
handful of parishes that don't have the
district councillor on them anyway so
you're not going to get false if you do
it that way you will not get 14 parish
councillors wanting to come on the
district training because those such as
Raley Hockey Hall called Rockford great
wakering boiling and Sutton they've all
got district councillors on them so
you're only probably looking up a
handful of parishes but don't have
district answers on them already that
will want to send somebody so why can't
you why don't I can't you do it through
it that way the district councillor
takes the risk of the district
councillor is also a parish council
takes the responsibility for taking that
planning training back to the parish in
the same way as you are asking a parish
councillor to take the train back to the
parish so let the district
I take it back they're the ones that
have to do it mandatory so why can't
they take it back to the paratroops your
penis just a few perishability quantity
it's the omnia among only to apply to
parish council where is that where there
is not an existing now that was
requirements posle the problem with
district councillors a plan meetings at
a parish level is it does came its own
circumstances give them a conflict of
interest so it would be difficult as a
planning meeting parish level for the
district councillor to shall we say
guide the parish councillors on a
particular planning matter because of
the conflict of interest so that's the
reason I say that it should be the
non-district parish councillors ok thank
you there ok so we're clear on that all
right it's under I'm going to go to a
vote now because I think we've had a
good discussion all those in favor of
council step those proposals and if
anybody wants it to be repeated I'm sure
Michelle what applies on that yes ok to
month and one space on each of the
planning training courses offered to
district councillors is available or it
can be offered to each of the parish
councils in the district so that gives
always measure of their every third term
is another one space be offered to each
of the parish councils on all of the
district council planning training
sessions things
all outside I should have a show of
hands of all those in favor and any
against so i think that is Carrie yeah
thank you ok any other returning out of
the agenda item or any other comments
that members wish to make of this
recommendation having you really quite
off it doesn't ever seem that the parish
councils ever actually been asked what
training they want and what's their
reasons for not attending sessions quite
a fat one I mean one article statistics
for the planning training for example
four parishes I as I told you one as a
two-dimension tonight 6.5 there are only
a few of parish and town councils that
keep sendin attendees there are
obviously reasons why some of those
parish councils simply do not send
attendee sorry visit just because of the
40-pound charge on a bit puzzled uses
six point six point five planning
training therefore planning training
sessions from september's when folks are
impatient for site yeah attendees 11
and 10 so they're quite consistently as
[ __ ] they only cover a few of there's no
details to the lines of ten difficulty
those attendees are coming from and your
few councils few parish councils why is
it that those other parish matters and
I'm not attending and not sending any of
them come forth I'm not asking to force
them I'm asking have we found out why
they are not coming is offering them up
one free base government can answer your
question I hopefully hopefully i'm not
sure their parishes hot people are
training pleased to be a hockey Perry
counselor hope you've got a training
budget if any of those parish
councillors want to go on any time you
cook not just what should outside the
area they put the place back and they
can go so they haven't got to say we're
not just sticking or what to do if we
weren't going to different rate also
completely different they get paid by
the parish and making she go so the geo
the ones that we offer I don't want to
do they don't have to but they may we go
somewhere yeah first I'm Sam what the
original question was a thing with
original comment was how do we get
parish councils to engage in the
district council training sessions in
particular planning and it doesn't ever
seem to have been a definitive answer
there must be a reason why how you
mentioned that the fee of 40 pounds per
delegate is often a starting point if
that's the case the figures we're
talking about are so minimal and then
you mentioned earlier about just
offering them as free three places and I
come back to me on that when I was a
parish counterpart as a counselor I went
on any training corset I could do and it
was paid for through the parish because
i want to give other training course you
can't make parish councillors and i know
not
Park Avenue in hockley of the pack it's
not totally agree with you but these
parish councils here they've submitted
their what their budgets are and then
you know with the greatest respect a lot
of them perhaps in any attendees to the
planning training that they attach their
decision and now we're off we can only
makes about you know there won't make
training available in appropriate cases
yes it's not for us to call them to
account I'm not as they decided I'll
make the magic but there must be reason
why there are not coming or going to do
not want to engage it must be the reason
why some of these parish councils I'm
not attending any of these sessions if
they are attending other planet sessions
organized by other councils or other
organizations which are free which are
cheaper which I veneer then it would be
just useful for us to know and to put
into a report for us to see if they're
just not attending those meetings
because they don't want to before
because they don't have the budget to
that would be interesting them I just
think we were there to sit here and come
up with a better idea but what it is
exactly the parishes want from us it's
all about what they want and what they
need and I'm just getting the impression
of as a district as we're not really
listening to them when we're not the
parishes Cooper's I'm sermon America but
the idea is to encourage them not make
them but to encourage them to engage and
yet we don't seem to actually be
listening to them and understanding what
it is they what that encouragement what
encouragement is needed that's just
don't like the lake with respect that
isn't our role without it's not whether
it's not our role true as it were look
after the parishes
then you my opinion eek what's the point
of sitting and discussing that we have
to ask many minutes offering in one
particular place but for you which we
consider to be appropriate but the atoms
in what they want cancer slept we are
having tomorrow parish site where the
parishes are coming to meeting between
the district I'm not sure what is on the
agenda but we do ask the parishes if
there's any particular topic that they
would like to include if the opportunity
arises I'm certainly happy to put that
to the parishes tomorrow the love Pat
Summitt we had we had representation
from every parish the last summit
meeting we had so hopefully they will
all be there tomorrow so I can perhaps
pose that question if the committee so
much giving your chin Cascione just to
quickly answer a counselor focus on I'm
sorry fed cancelled Burton in the parrot
in the parish they've also regulated
through the EEOC and the ELC of provided
training courses and so it's up to the
individual parishes to the side which
training courses which don't want their
counselors to go on but again I'm not
disputing it would just be useful to
know if they are choosing those courses
over what we don't know what we are able
to offer them I just think it would be
help us decide the right partly you
nothing thank you Jim my experience on
the rogers hundred is the it is indeed
the cost of 40 pounds the stop sign of
the parishes attending our training
sessions and I accept that they do pay
other people's like the EA MC for the
Eternity accessions but i also want to
support counter stepped out upon always
going to raise it the question as to
what trained into parishes need from us
should we discussed at the
Paris summit so I've got the nice boys
okay that might be useful to if I'm
opportunity given the opportunity arises
on us or what's been fixed in the agenda
as of yet so I'm noticed something on
I'm my sister not sure what you think we
should to be doing with the information
even if you thought it but I think the
question was if I'm correct me if I'm
wrong here is a question to all our skis
what training do the deed parishes think
the district the question yeah and more
currently prevents them going engaging
more than they are so and I think that
just be useful when we see this football
perhaps next year with pom still view
next year I think it would be useful for
us to see it so that when we discuss how
we going forward in association with
parish council I just think it would
give us a better insight to what I
needed with darker as was your question
so I'll girls like just I'm just looking
it is come on why do the hot baby boy no
honest all their job they're listed
which I I change sometimes chairman fine
butters say the same question should be
put back through to the lottery hundreds
of association local councils and
towards their few which is
representation for all the parishes of
that meeting it's the same question to
the answer there's I'm happy to bring it
up next meeting
alright so the recommendation is to that
the committee resolves that you report
be noted though it is noted that feel a
lot lighter recommendation to Council
one free space oh I'm sorry yes yes
Prince ramón on it so we are going to
add if the committee agreed a proposal
that this committee recommends to full
council the one go through it all again
they're taking my baby the most
important just agreed okay and that
being the last item on the agenda with
that I impair the amazing clothes at a
24 thank you ma'am